Shrut, ¿podía cumplir con todas las cosas del judaísmo?
¿Cómo se podía cumplir? ¿Cómo se podía cumplir?
¿Era Shoahat? ¿Era Kasher?
¿Y rezaba?
¿Quién lo quiso?
¿Usted?
Yo, siempre.
Como sea, con hambre, sin hambre, con sabor, sin sabor, siempre mire.
Jamás, no voy a hacer.
No voy a mirar.
Hasta el último momento de mi vida.
¿Quiere saber qué pasó en Sonora?
Estuvo ocho meses en el gueto. ¿Cuál fue ese sábado que salió?
¿Qué día era?
El sábado.
¿Pero qué fecha? ¿Qué año?
No puedo decir qué fecha.
Era el año, el principio del 43.
¿El principio del 43?
Sí.
¿Invierno qué era?
Si era invierno, no, no era invierno.
Era en tiempo, te voy a decirte.
Era Semana Santa.
Semana Santa era, era como mes de mayo o junio, era.
¿En el 43?
Sí, me acuerdo, como yo andaba de Sobibor para Crejo, con zapatos, sí, era así.
Cuénteme, entonces, qué pasó ese día.
Salí yo con mi señora, y agarraron, y llevaban a la misma terreno a donde Sobibor, a donde Bratz Mustard.
¿Por qué salieron ese día?
Yo digote, que salió con mi señora para un remedio bucal para, ella no se sentía bien.
Y como tenía permiso que yo pudiera salir, entonces me agarraron y me dijeron que esto no vale nada.
Cuando lo hicieron, era de valor, cuando no lo hicieron, no era de valor.
Tú sabes cómo eran, eran en tiempo, hermanos.
Y cuando llevaron a nosotros para el terreno, ya era mucha gente allá.
Era el sábado.
Llevaron mucho, y agarraron de todas partes, agarraron, mucho.
Y se metieron en camiones hasta el tren.
¿Cómo eran esos camiones?
Camiones militares, camiones militares, como acá.
¿Y cuánta gente había en los camiones?
Alemanes.
¿Cuántas personas metían en los camiones?
Parado, había sentado, todo parado, como palos, parados.
Cada uno estaba yeso, y yo sabía de dónde me voy.
¿Y qué pensaba?
Oh, esa es la cosa que usted más hace pregunta.
Que yo pensaba, que no hay fuerza del mundo que me pueda dominar a mí.
Le voy a decirte un facto, mire.
Cuando se me estaba encerrado en tren y vagón,
mi señora tenía 20 años.
Entonces grita en vagón, mire.
Todo el mundo llorando, mire.
Tenía que llorar.
Todavía no se me hicieron vida.
Todavía no tuvimos hijos.
Padres y madres ya quemaron hermanos.
¿Por qué toca a nosotros?
¿Quién decía eso?
Esto.
Entonces yo dijo así, oírme.
Con calma, con tranquilidad.
Mi hija.
Cada uno está escrito en la historia que tiene que vivir 70 años.
Vamos a hacer una foto.
Ya tenemos 70 años.
Ya son todavía hijos.
Ya estaban casados.
Ya tenemos nietos.
Cada uno tiene suerte en su muerte.
A nosotros toca esa muerte.
Mi amor.
Te digo con palabra, con fuerza de Dios que nosotros no vamos a morir.
No vamos a morir.
Ella me contesta.
Adam.
Ya tú estás loco.
Esa es la palabra.
Y empezó a llorar.
¿Cómo eran los vagones, señor Adam?
Como todos los vagones que usted ve, mire.
Usted no estuvo en Estados Unidos, no estuvo en Miami, no estuvo en adónde.
Entraron los mismos vagones, mismo.
Entraron los vagones.
No se sentaron, estaban así.
¿Y cuánta gente iba en cada vagón?
Entraron 40, 50, 60, 100.
Uno tenía que pensar, mire, de cuánto hay y de cuánto no hay.
En ese tiempo, mire.
¿Cuánto duró el viaje?
¿Cómo?
Diez minutos.
De tren para Subíbalo, mucho era diez minutos.
No pudo entrar, entró el tren de nosotros.
Entró también trenes de otras ciudades.
Helm, Lublin, Via Lepotazka.
¿Al mismo tiempo que ustedes?
Sí, entonces yo, mire.
Ya se quemaron, en primer comentario, millones de gente se quemaron allá.
En primer comentario.
¿Cómo fue la llegada? Cuénteme cada detalle.
Me llegaron el sábado de la noche, abrieron las puertas, salir.
Salieron.
Y dentro de media hora, el señor me llamó nada más.
Le conoció que yo soy loco, ¿no?
Cada hombre busca a su mujer.
Pero cuando usted llegó, ¿qué vio?
¿Qué fue lo primero que vio al abrir las puertas del tren?
¿Qué se vi, mire?
Había pancartas, árboles, ¿cómo? ¿Qué es lo que vio?
Nada.
Puro electricidad de todo.
Redondo.
¿Fue caminando y vaya contando?
No, se empujaron.
El tren es entrar adentro del terreno, donde está cerrado.
No afuera, que uno entra adentro, adonde estaba el crematorio,
adonde estaba todo electricizado.
Que uno quiese salir, se llama electricidad.
Y media hora, viene orden.
Cada hombre busca a su mujer.
Entonces, allá pasó mi fin.
Lloraron.
Mucho.
Como llegó una locura.
¿Por qué no llaman inmediatamente a nosotros?
Ya sabes que van a quemar.
¿Por qué llaman a nosotros más?
¡Ojalá que llamen ya!
Miren, señores.
Esto, que yo lo vi, y que yo tenía que pasar,
y en este momento yo no creo solo que es verdad,
que yo estoy diciendo un busto.
En este momento yo no creo solo que es verdad,
¡Haz mi asomayen!